à controverse
et quand j'ai vu j'ai vécu le la
propagande quand j'ai entendu
moi qui avais une connaissance à cause
de mon passé et de ma formation je suis
ingénieur en énergie quand j'ai entendu
ce que j'entendais quand je voyais des
petits hélicoptères arrosée en disant ça
va leur fera dire ce qui est juste alors
que c'était juste pour stabiliser la
poussière mais en aucun cas ça pouvait
ça ne pouvaient refroidir un réacteur
je me suis dit que là il y avait
vraiment la propagande dépassait
c'est-à-dire dépassait les ce que je
pensais imaginez et ensuite le hasard de
la vie a fait que j'ai rencontré un
retraité qui s'appelle andré parisse
avec lequel il a participé à la
rédaction ce livre qui lui a vécu la
même chose est la même on va dire
retraité de coin lui les retraités
étaient géologue il a travaillé pour
total voilà il a travaillé aussi
il me semble en relation avec le seum et
là je voudrais je suis pas sûr mais il a
travaillé avec des grosses
multinationales chercher du pétrole donc
c'est un géologue et là il a
mis au point suite à l'accident de
tchernobyl une méthode de détection des
de la radioactivité dans le sol parce
que c'est assez compliqué pour l'estimer
correctement si on a envie de l'estimé
donc sa méthode il l'a mis au point lui
même et il a travaillé pour le
excusez moi la criirad voilà c'est il a
travaillé pour la criirad et la criirad
qui est la criirad qui a été fondée
par la députée européenne
d'europe écologie
actuellement qui voulait se présenter
excusez moi le nom m'échappe alors je
vais reprendre la parole on va dire à
nos auditeurs que vous arrivez en direct
de kinshasa et que vous avez vite heures
de vol dans les pattes est-ce que vous
avez pris de vol à venir et que
exceptionnellement on vous prend comme
ça à chaud et c'est pour ça que vous
êtes un peu voilà je peux avoir des
liens du 2 janvier voilà en fait bon
l'huile à travailler pour la créer la
criirad il a mis au point la créat c'est
un institut indépendant qui étaient
fondées
suite
à tchernobyl par des gens qui étaient
horrifiés de légende des scientifiques
des scientifiques qui étaient horrifiés
par la propagande de l'état français et
ils ont rien au point cet institut qui
est reconnue qui fait des analyses de
radioactivité est en vrai parisse a mis
au point une méthode méthode tellement
point que le cea s'est mis à l'utiliser
après pour savoir aussi et lui a vécu a
vécu cet hymne à raconter
cette attitude prise de conscience de la
propagande et cette personne-là a passé
vingt ans à
essayez d'analyser et de démonter la
fois le système de propagande
de l'état français et surtout il fixait
un scientifique il s'est mis à collecter
beaucoup d'informations beaucoup
d'analystes sur la france et sur
l'europe il a fait la cartographie de la
contamination de la vraie contamination
de tchernobyl et il a fait aussi il a
fait 13 voyages avec les enfants de
tchernobyl une association qui aide qui
aide les enfants de la région de
tchernobyl à se soigner grâce à un
institut qui a été qu'ils s'appellent
l'institut belgrade qui a été
complètement veut dire boycotté par tous
les grands instituts
européens qui sont qui font partie en
fait qu'ils interviennent là bas avait
classé la cpr le cockpit de communité
permanent d'informations sur la sur la
radioactivité qui est un comité qui
dépend de l'onu et dont tout monsieur
yves lenoir l'a démontré dans un la
comédie atomique dans un dans un livre
qui vient de paraître est paru l'année
dernière où ils démontent ça de manière
très claire
est un institut qui qui au service en
fait des états nucléaires et qui équipe
tous fait de la propagande donc j'ai
essayé des voix là juste pour terminer
pourquoi j'ai fait ce livre entend on a
le temps voilà c'est qu'en fait ayant
travaille aussi dans l'accord il y en a
un peu les deux compétences et un
travail un peu dans la communication
j'avais déjà rédigé des livres j'avais
travaillé sur le web et faisons d'un peu
d aussi des conférences qu'on appelle
des conférences gesticulées qui est de
la vulgarisation scientifique je me suis
dit qu'en par rapport à ces gens là
qu'avaient de l'information mais qu'ils
avaient du mal à toucher le grand public
par rapport
à l'aspect complexe et qui avait une
certaine en plus c'est des gens qui se
retrouvent dans une position qu'ils sont
très critiqués donc ils ont dû ils ont
du mal à simplifier il reste un haut
niveau scientifique pour échapper aux
critiques
ce qui fait qu'ils restent inaudibles au
niveau du grand public et moi j'ai voulu
essayer de démonter sa de parler
calmement
motorisés certaine imprécision certaine
forme d'humour bref une certaine forme
d'humour pour aussi
être audible c'est à dire que n'importe
qui peut lire on n'a pas besoin d'être
d'avoir une formation d'ingénieur et
connaître le tableau de mendeleïev pour
pouvoir lire ce livre est aussi
rassembler toute une série
d'informations qui me semblait utile
dans une démarche intellectuelle pour
déconstruire ce discours qui était
construit patiemment depuis 50 ans pour
nous faire accepter le nucléaire et
comprendre à la fois les risques
en comprenant comment fonctionne de
manière simple une centrale nucléaire
comprendre quels événements et quels
risques potentiels peuvent nous amener à
l'accident nucléaire et quand l'accident
nucléaire arrive
comment il peut être
on va dire presque bénin
graves comme fukushima très graves comme
comme tchernobyl lit que grave fukushima
oui les gras non il est que oui les cas
graves parce qu' il va pour nous pour
moi
l'analyse que j'en fais c'est que la
grande chance de fukushima c'est qu'ils
ont eue d'un vent d'ouest est un nid le
plus grand océan du monde l'ide juste à
côté qu'est ce que vous pensez du fait
que tout coup
face des lâchers d'eau contaminée dans
ce fameux océans
bailly
ils essayent de minimiser les coûts de
cet accident parce qu'en fait un
accident nucléaire coûte une fortune
et stocker qu'est ce que vous appelez
une fortune à 200 300 500 milliards il
est même un accident nucléaire c'est
c'est la moitié d'un pib quoi
vous avez travaillé sur la récupération
d'une galette de corium c'est ça ouais
on appelle ça une galette de corium
l'apesa du leu le corium du corium c'est
un corium c'est à dire que ces mélanges
de du coeur le coeur fondu comment
comment quelle température ça prend
ça peut percer combien de couches de
béton quelle épaisseur de béton il nous
faut pour pouvoir gérer une fonte d'un
coeur
pur si une nappe phréatique en dessous
qu'est ce qu'on fait en fait tout le
souci du nucléaire c'est une fois que
c'est sorti de là plusieurs barrières
barrière des crayons et la barrière du
coeur alors il faut expliquer les
barrières des crayons si vous parlez des
crayons de combustible excellent
combustible alors des combustible à
l'uranium ou un petit peu mélangé avec
du plutonium du mox on parle de quel
type de crayon la wii les que le
combustible radioactif et et
est gainé c'est à dire qu'il est mis
dans une dire la capsule ll est en
zirconium qui est un métal
très solide dans lequel on emprisonne la
matière dans lequel il ya de l'uranium
au départ qui se transforme en plutonium
quelque chose de très dangereux avec
lequel on fabrique les bombes donc nos
bombes sont fabriqués au plutonium
et
si ses crayons lâchent ils lâchent la
radioactivité ils peuvent lâcher dans le
coeur si le coeur fond il le lâche dans
l'enceinte où il ya du béton et 6
l'enceinte qui l'a dernier rempart lâche
sa part dans la chaîne alimentaire sa
part dans la nature et quand ces partis
dans la chaîne alimentaire
eh ben le plutonium plus ton dieu de
l'enfer dieu de l'enfer c'est pas pour
rien qu'on a choisi ce nom ça dure la
demi vie c'est à dire que c'est à dire
que le temps que ça diminue de moitié
ses 24 milan et impute omnium de tueur
mais cette fois sur l'uranium non 24
mille ans
mais une demi vie c'est en fait une demi
vie c'est un indice scientifique qui
donne qui donne pas en fait là il faut
multiplier par 10 pour avoir une vraie
idée de combien de temps ça dure pour
qu'il y ait plus rien pour que ce soit
d'autre oui besoin de l'autre on peut
dire que si un accident nucléaire on
revienne dans 250 mille ans n'y a plus
rien la nature reprendra il faut pas
croire que c'est
pourquoi on appelle ça uranium
d'ailleurs vous connaissez la petite
légende autour de l'uranium non on va
chez elle va demander à nous internautes
de la chercher ça va les faire barrer
revenons revenons à votre livre est
votre démarche intellectuelle quand vous
voyez la passivité intellectuelle des je
vais dire des gens de la plèbe de la
population française face aux risques
que l'état
peut faire prendre à nos générations
futures qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
est ce que ça vous empêche de dormir à
ce que ça vous révolte est ce que vous
avez envie de diffuser votre savoir un
maximum
ça vous donne des perspectives d'avenir
à ce que vous pensez à la capacité de
résilience des gens sur leurs capacités
aussi à comprendre les risques et les
enjeux
pendant un moment je vais demander si
j'étais un pas un peu comme dans le film
oui à celui qui à monsieur vincent et
c'est qu'il ya les aliens voilà c'est
david vincent david vincent voilà on
sait et c'est qu'il ya un problème et
tout le monde tout le monde le prend
pour un fou et ça ça a été
ça a été la grande misère de beaucoup de
gens qui présentent d'entrée par isme
tous ces gens là qui ont lutté contre le
nucléaire pendant une époque on les a
vraiment pris pour des allumés on les a
fait passer pour elle on les a fait
passer plutôt pour
car il ya une propagande qui est ému
quand 58 le msc jamais je vais pas faire
trop de citations mais celle-là journal
temps y'a 1 l'om est fait une étude sur
le nucléaire et en 58 et 10 du point de
vue de la santé mentale la situation la
solution les plus satisfaisants pour
l'avenir des utilisations pacifiques de
l'énergie atomique serait de voir monter
une nouvelle génération qui aurait
appris à s'accommoder de l'ignorance et
de la certitude
il faut l'om est recommande d'installer
les réacteurs nucléaires plus tôt près
des lieux de vie pour que les gens
soient rassurés parce qu'on s'est aperçu
que psycho uniquement par exemple des
gens qui habitent à côté d'un barrage
sont sûrs que le barrage va tenir les
gens qui sont un peu élevées beaucoup
plus éloignés eux mais qui sont quand
même sous le barrage commence à être
plus inquiet donc pas honte la décision
de mettre à nogent quand même
centrale nucléaire de nogent à paris
paris
y'a pas beaucoup d'habitants un baril
voilà s'il faut évacuer la capitale ça
fait quand même du monde dans les alpes
ça fait quand même parce que la
problématique qui a eu aussi c'est pour
ça que je dis à fukushima c'est pas
cette pas été trop grave parce que on
peut évacuer fukushima on peut évacuer
30 km au toit on peut évacuer tokyo non
on ne peut pas l'évacuer tokyo on peut
pas évacuer paris donc nos gens ont peut
pas évacuer on ne peut pas effectuer nos
gens devraient enfin c'est une folie
sachant que l'électricité se transporte
bien avec les lignes haute tension yao
qui avait aucun problème à m aucun
réacteur nucléaire près de paris quoi
mais celui-là il a été fait pour
[Musique]
la preuve raison vos proches votre
entourage
et donc sensibilisés à ses risques et
périls et
et est ce que votre entourage est venu
vous voir en vous disant mais josé mais
tu es en train de péter un boulard pour
rien tu peux être un plan pour rien
regarde ce qu'ils disent à lattes et
tout se passe bien le nuage n'a pas
traversé la frontière
à l'est qu'est-ce que josy leur dis ben
c'est vrai que mon entourage j'ai fini
par les fatiguer avec avec mes
préoccupations
un jour mon nom je passe sur l'autoroute
il y avait une centrale nucléaire et moi
et mon fils dit amour à mon deuxième
fils qui est plus petit dit tu vois ça
c'est ça qui va nous tuer et là je me
suis dit ouh j'ai peut-être que
peut-être un peu forcé la dose avec eux
ou pas ou pas mais bon ces décès des
enfants et sort de la bouche des enfants
mais c'est vrai que là la douane
française est quand même très
performante c'est à dire qu'elle est
capable d'arrêter des particules
radioactives et le mensonge qui a été
construit à tchernobyl où on a arrêté ou
toute centrale nucléaire à arrêter ces
capteurs parce que parce que si s'il
arrêtait pas le capteur tous les
capteurs des toute centrale nucléaire
est équipé d'un capteur qui hurlent si
la dose des passes pour évacuer la
population il y en a ils ont tout
débrancher sinon tous les réacteurs
français austra mis à hurler ce qui
était gênant
on a laissé manger aux gens du lait et
des champignons ce que n'ont pas fait
les autrichiens les italiens est
actuellement le premier consommateur de
lait voti rocks c'est à dire le
médicament qui soigne la thyroïde ses
décors ce nom ouais c'est les corses et
les français 9 millions de boîtes et 2
c'est le deuxième médicament le plus
avaler en france après le doliprane
problèmes de thyroïde ouais et quand le
présent par andré baril smara compter
que quand les enfants les malades de la
thyroïde ont fait un procès j'ai eu un
procès qui a été fait au docteur
qui vient de mourir le fameux docteur
qui avait dit le type de
nuage de tchernobyl n'est pas passé en
france et tout va bien ils nous ont fait
un procès et au procès ils ont voulu
savoir demander à la sécu est-ce que
combien de boîtes de lait rôti rock
s'est vendu en france vu que c'est
remboursé la sécu à des statistiques
surtout il n'arrivait pas à voir la
statistique il a fallu qu'un juge qui
s'énerve pour qu'ils obtiennent la
statistique c'est un détail c'est un
détail mais qui résume bien la
fabrication du mensonge qui a été fait
pour
pour pour que la population continue à
rester dans l'ignorance ça a bien marché
après il ya eu la déconstruction de qui
a été fait par
part par la mission de l'onu l'un d'eux
sur la sur les conséquences de
tchernobyl en disant que c'était les
russes c'était la faute c'était pas un
problème nucléaire c'est un problème
communiste sachant que il faut ici on va
dire que si c'est un accident nucléaire
se reproduisait
je vais dire heureusement qu'à l'époque
ça s'est passé dans un état communiste
un sous l'égide de la russie parce
qu'ils ont sacrifié des gens à la façon
des communistes ils ont ils ont envoyé
des gens dévoués pour protéger les
autres et en nombre on appelait ça
comment les liquidateurs sa guise les
500000 liquidateur
le gg je voudrais je voudrais vous poser
une question sur les risques terroristes
et les centrales nucléaires quand vous
entendez un drones survolant de nuit une
centrale nucléaire peut-être avec une
caméra thermique pour voir où se trouve
le transformateur de régulation
thermique la centrale
qu'est ce que vous en tant que vous en
pensez est ce que pour 10 euros 50 et le
prix d'un drone on peut arriver à faire
basculer une centrale nucléaire
je pense pas je ne pense pas que je
pense qu'il faut investir un peu plus
mais ça j'aurais du mal à répondre
techniquement sur avec le drôme mais il
est clair que à l'époque où été conçu
les centrales nucléaires c'est à dire
les années 60 c'est une vieille
technologie 57 et mis au point ces
débits au point par l'armée américaine
on n'a jamais on a fait 40 ans de
recherche on n'a jamais fait mieux que
la première la première solution inventé
par l'armée américaine la plus simple de
l'eau de l'eau pressurisée et
encore un truc qui montre l'impasse du
nucléaire mais
il n'a pas été pensé le problème du
terrorisme dans les années 60 parce que
c'était du ressort de l'état et qu'à
l'époque il n'y avait pas de terrorisme
comme ça et on peut faire abattre en il
suffirait de faire abattre un avion moi
je verrais plutôt un avion sûr sur les
piscines sur l'attitude de stockage pour
les piscines de stockage qui ne sont pas
qu'ils sont qui contiennent des fois
plus de radioactivité künker réacteurs
nucléaires et qui sont pas protégés et
là on nous dit l'état dit bah non il n'y
a pas de problème c'est son prix des
piscines et quand on conçoit le p r on
met un bunker sur les piscines alors
soit ça sert à rien soit il faut en
mettre à tous les autres sur les 56
réacteurs français voilà seulement quand
on multiplie 200 millions par 58 ça fait
un joli de vie et lafarge là ils ont il
ya quelques sacs de ciment à mener et ce
qui est par contre au niveau du
terrorisme il ya tout un tas de
faiblesses c'est à dire que par exemple
les générateurs de secours n'ont pas
être toujours été conçu au bon endroit
les organes de commande l'avion pourrait
viser les organes de commande peut-être
qu'un drone qui connaît bien après il ya
quand même dans les réacteurs nucléaires
une redondance les appareils de sécurité
donc normalement 6 1 est annulé il en
reste deux
deux technologies donc il ya quand même
elle a été pensée la sécurité en il faut
pas dire que la porte reste nationale
n'a pas été pensée a été pensé elle a
été même bien pensé moi je juge ait pas
de problème à le dire même si par contre
elle n'a pas pensé à tout et le souci
c'est que par rapport à l'industrie où
on se dit allez on va bien pensé à tous
à tous
à tout la sécurité d'eads est en guerre
on va mettre deux on va en mettre des
doubles coques et comme ça on aura
presque jamais d'accident pétroliers
rien n'aura jamais eu d'accident 13
pétroliers ça va être vrai en fait ça va
être vrai ceux qui veulent m'avoir au
lieu d'en avoir un tout les ans ils vont
en avoir un tous les 20 ans mais il y
aura toujours et là dans la technologie
nucléaire on a droit à zéro faute
d'herbe zéro accident sinon et c'est là
où la propagande elle a été forte c'est
à dire quelles sont les conséquences
d'un accident et les conséquences d'un
accident est son énorme et surtout les
faiblesses si d'un coup ça a été pensé
pour pas que ça pète dans un
fonctionnement normal si là il ya par
exemple un terroriste qui s'amusent à
faire sauter une péniche dans les
écluses de donzère qui fait 26 mai aps
n'est pas donner de mauvaises idées
ouais c'est vrai faudrait pas la dire
celle là voilà opale à dire celle là
mais
les gens qu'ils commencent à regarder le
problème ils peuvent vraiment trouver là
veut dire le grain de sable mais moi il
n'y a pas que ça qui me fait peur il ya
le fait aussi que n'a pas été pensé
le changement climatique qui fait qu'il
ya des choses qui n'existaient pas que
par exemple refroidissement pour parler
du refroidissement die du
refroidissement des malades est par
exemple on a mis des recteurs au bord de
la mer en disant il n'y aura jamais plus
de 100 kilomètres/heure et où 120
enfants de la prégnance ménat coût des
tempêtes par exemple blaye et en 99 ans
a failli blaye à côté de bordeaux le
réacteur nucléaire
c'est un entonnoir il au fond de
l'entonnoir de la gironde est comme ça
le recteur ici et il y avait des
marécages
et quand il y avait une tempête les
marécages servait d ponge et d'un
couvent ces terres qui sont très
fertiles les paysans sont dit on va les
transformer en nomadisme politique
agricole fait plein d'argent avec le
maïs ça produit bien ils ont tous
transformer leur mariage en maïs et en
vingt ans ça a été fait
arrive la tempête martin 99 au lieu d'
amortir lui
cette honte aux noirs au lieu que les
marécages amortissent le la vague elle
est directement et sannois y ait le
coeur ça le noyer le blayais et si les
techniciens
n'avaient pas préparé le bug de l'an
2000 parce que le bug de l'an 2000 sa
fillette le black out en france parce
que le 27 décembre le 27 décembre quand
arrive la tempête martin et que le
blayais
et ils ont lu c'est à dire que n'a plus
d'alimentation électrique il a les
techniciens ont été formés ils ont fait
le plein de fuel et le ré et les
générateurs de secours dont certains
sont sous l'eau
arrive à
remettre et arrive à refroidir la
centrale et là on est passé vraiment
très près de la catastrophe
le juppé a été on a téléphoné à juppé en
disant que peut-être on a il allait se
passer quelque chose de grave et surtout
le 27 à cause de la tempête qui a fait
couler l'erika
il a fallu avoir un black out à une
ligne près ça c'est un technicien d'edf
qui travaillent dans le réseau qui me
l'a raconté à une ligne précisé qu il ya
une liquide qui sautaient et toute la
france était dans le noir et c'est toute
la france était dans le noir il y avait
58 réacteurs qui devait sicile au t6
l'hôte et c'est à dire ceux
s'autosuffire en électricité s'alimenter
eux mêmes et la folle et espérer que ça
se passe bien et là on n'est pas passé
loin et par contre on n'a parlé que de
l'erika
et on a eu affaire aussi à des
techniciens qui étaient dire qu'ils
étaient qui était qui ont été
performants sur ce succès il ya eu ça
aussi qui a été construit la performance
française c'est à dire que les russes
s'étaient ils étaient pas bon alors ce
que c'est pas du tout ce qui n'est pas
du tout vrai
il faut il faut aussi prendre en compte
dans les dents les risques c'est le fait
que on a un outil qui edf qui en train
de se dégrader dans lequel on applique
les mêmes politiques libérales où on dit
ben la maintenance ça rapporte rien donc
on économise dedans on baisse les coûts
on sous traite en cascade on
déresponsabilise les gens ont les dents
l'aider qualifie les faut voir un ceux
qui font le nucléaire on les appelle
dans le langage d'edf il appelle les
steaks carême laissera les rênes c'est
les unités de mesure 2 2 de combien on
appris de radioactivité dans dans la
figure et eux ils servent c'est des gens
qui sont
pas si bien payer pour les risques
qu'ils prennent qui sont désinformés ça
ceux qui nettoient qui sait qu'ils vont
faire le boulot et les agents edf sont
les patrons
c'est à dire c'est lui qui signe les
papiers dieu qui contrôle les
alternatives à tous ces risques est ce
qu'il ya des préconisations affaires
préconisations simple compliqué complexe
est-ce que vous avez chiffré ces
préconisations
vous écoute ben en fait il ya plein de
choses qui seraient qui serait vraiment
facile à faire dans un premier temps
c'est à dire que
sélectionné les dix ou quinze centrales
les plus pourris en france et les fermes
et directement sa le faire le check up
et les fermer edf ferait des économies
sachant que ça veut dire qu'ils font
m'arrêterai d'exporter y aura un coût
c'est ça qu'on aime parce qu'il ya à peu
près un paquet de centrales qui servent
en fait
à exporter du cerveau dire aux
gaspillages parce qu'en fait on a
institué le gaspillage dire qu'on a vu
qu'on avait construit trop de centrales
on a voulu on en a on a incité à la
consommation ça serait assez simple de
réduire la consommation si elles voient
une volonté politique est enfermé une
dizaine arrêter d'utiliser le plutonium
c'est à dire le mox c'est à dire la
saisir réinjecter du plutonium dans du
dent dure dans des crayons de
combustible d'ingrédients rustine 9
juste pour faire marcher les usines de
retraitement de la hague donc on préfère
mélagues qui est nulle usine la plus
polluante du monde
déjà on fait ça et investir beaucoup
d'argent dans la sécurité donc payer les
gens correctement
pauvres dit que la hague l usine la plus
polluante
qui existe parce qu'elles rejettent du
plutonium en grosse quantité dans
l'océan les sources de ça c'est quoi il
ya un rapport qui a été fait que j'ai
citées dans 20 cas jeudi la plus
polluante du monde en terme de
radioactivité parce que je crois qu'il
ya des gens qui s'amusent à retraiter le
plutonium il ya
les russes
et les français voilà il y en a que deux
usines et on s'est mis on s'est lancés
veut dire de la spécificité française
c'est l'amour du plutonium
qui permet aussi de ne pas dire qu'en
retraite le plutonium
derrière tout ça dans la filière
nucléaire
retraitées ça veut dire quoi cela veut
dire qu'on prend le plutonium dans le
temps dans les crayons usagers
et au lieu de au lieu de stocker ça
comme un déchet on leur remet pour un
tour c'est à dire ça peut encore
fissionner dans dans des dents des
crayons neuf c'est à dire qu'on
réutilise donnant le nom de ou 30 ans on
s'est serré ou 6% ouais ça permet
d'économiser quelques pourcentages de
c'est à dire ça évite d'acheter parce
que 0 % de l'uranium français est
produit en france en dix ans on est
épuisé en fait il ya aucune capacité
donc le plutonium sert sert juste un jeu
dire à faire tourner la hague dont il ya
aucun intérêt à part qui a un intérêt
quand même géopolitique c'est que on
peut quand quand on fait passer des
extraits plutonium sont peu le
réinjecter soit on peut extraire pour en
faire de la bombe donc qu'on maîtrise le
combustible nucléaire de d'un pays on
maîtrise un peu sa capacité à fabriquer
ou pas des bons de quoi lasser c'est un
peu plus compliqué maintenant l arme
nucléaire a été mise hors la loi par 166
pays ou quelque chose comme ça parlons
un petit peu des déchets nucléaires
on fait quoi on les stocke comment ça va
où et comment comment vous géré le
problème en france comment agir le
problème en france ben on le gère pour
l'instant on ne gère pas quoi on stocke
dans un coin en stock dans un coin on
essaye de faire un trou à bure pour
l'enfouir ce qui risque d'être pire que
ce que que le laisser dans une piscine à
l'air libre enfin dans une piscine au
niveau du sol n'y a rien à il n'y a rien
à faire qu'à attendre avec le vous
pouvez les gens n'auront jamais compris
ne comprennent pas eskimos j'essaie de
leur faire comprendre qu est ce que la
radioactivité l'originalité c'est
quelque chose vous pouvez vous prenez
quelque chose de radioactifs vous pouvez
le mettre à n'importe quelle température
mais de l'acide de la base vous pouvez
mettre la pression vous voulez ça ne
bouge pas ça ne bouge ça continue est ce
que est ce que ça va être la croix des
jeunes générations de français est ce
que ça va être la malédiction est ce
qu'on va être obligé de faire pénitence
sur 50 génération ben moi j'essaye de
dire que le nucléaire je les ai pas mis
dans l'île mais pour moi le nucléaire
c'est l'équivalent de nous ont apporté à
notre génération la porte et lol la
croix de la colonisation c'est-à-dire
qu'on nous a beaucoup reproché eu
beaucoup de problèmes savoir qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on avait fait avec la
colonisation donc c'est quelque chose
c'est des problèmes qui ont été transmis
à la génération suivante le nucléaire
c'est là c'est la colonisation de donc
une choix dont les dont les conséquences
sont énormes
voilà pour moi c'est je le met en
parallèle avec la colonisation hélas le
non dit qu'il ya dans le nucléaire moi
je le met en parallèle avec la
pédophilie dans l'église c'est à dire
que un jour ça va c'est ça va sortir
c'est là que c'est quelque chose qui
était un non dit que tous les initiés
connaissait moi j'ai entendu des
histoires depuis longtemps et le jour où
ça commence à sortir on va les gens vont
vont prendre le vertige mais tous tous
les concepteurs du plan nucléaire
française seront morts on aura plus
personne pour se retourner
est ce que vous connaissez le thorium
les centrales au thorium oui qu'est ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire
le thorium c'est une technologie
nucléaire qui est plus sûr mais qui
produit pas de plutonium donc les
les à conduire
les sciences les militaires ont préféré
la technologie qui produit du plutonium
parce qu'en fait avoir une centrale
nucléaire c'est c'est avoir la bombe en
kit pourquoi l'iran ils veulent des
centrales nucléaires pourquoi l'arabie
saoudite est devenue centrale nucléaire
pourquoi le pourquoi là l'afrique du sud
est à construire deux centrales
nucléaires ces prêts qui sont elles
oui c'est cette problématique nucléaire
et donc le temps riaumont mais le
thorium fruits c'est une belle idée
cccc l'énergie de l'avenir et ça le
restera il ya aucune perspective avec le
thorium parce que la complexité de cette
énergie qui est le nucléaire la rend
difficilement
utile d'y avoir une ville l'énergie
enfin moi c'est mon avis une énergie
sans sa maîtrise n'est rien les
les romains maîtrisait très bien l'hydro
le concept de l'hydraulique il le
maîtrise est ils n'ont jamais trop
développées ils ont mis du temps à le
développer parce que unis l'avaient des
esclaves pas cher et de deux il ne
maîtrisait pas les vilebrequin des
pièces essentielles donc avoir l'énergie
la vapeur les les romains connaissaient
le principe de la vapeur mais
impossible de mettre qu'on maîtrise pas
une énergie on ne peut pas l'utiliser
c'est la même chose avec la fusion la
fusion nucléaire
cc1 maîtrisable donc la question n'est
pas
là question est caduque on peut pas
enlever le on peut pas enlever
il ya moins de risque avec le thorium
quand même c'est une demi vie c'est 600
ans la demi vie du temps du thorium
c'est surtout que ça peut s'étendre tout
seul c'est à dire que la centrale peut
s'éteindre tout seul et qui a dans sa
conception - pas de problème de
refroidissement parce que en fait d'un
livre m'amuse à dire que si vous aviez
une voiture nucléaire ça je voulais
juste si on a des prototypes de voitures
nucléaire dont je me sentis mais si si
si vous aviez une voiture nucléaire vous
changer les modèles tous les cinquante
ans la sécurité sera la même que celle
des années 50 ou 60 vous payerez le
carburant le même prix que vous
observiez ou pas le forfait carburant
illimité vous pousserez à la
consommation
pour l'arrêter il faut arriver à
destination vous devriez faire tourner
le moteur encore une semaine pour la
refroidir complètement sous peine de la
voir exploser et votre région rasé il
serait impératif de toujours avoir de
l'essence et de loups rôdent en fait
doucement pour pas qu'elle n'explose
vous ne devriez pas avoir d' accidents
de la route aucune assurance ne voudrais
vous assurer tout le monde paiera les
dégâts en cas d'accident aucune casse
n'existerait vous devriez payer le prix
de la voiture pour la démonter
qu'est ce que vous pensez du charbon
vous êtes peut-être pas expert dans le
charbon parce que le charbon c'est pire
que le nucléaire
et après avant que vous répondiez à la
question après j'ai vraiment envie de
vous mettre dans la peau d'un pro
nucléaires à
exercice
le charbon les charbons très très poli
très polis le produit du co2 donc du
changement climatique
est ce qu'on préfère la mort lente ou la
mort rapide cessé d alternatives
pour moi il existe une et il existe un
réacteur nucléaire pour moi l'avenir
c'est celle du clair
le nucléaire et l'avenir il existe un
réacteur nucléaire très très utile qui a
été placée à 300 millions de kilomètres
le second brille le soleil avec une
distance de sécurité aux normes d'une
vraie sécurité
ce réacteur à fusion il suffit
de capter un dix millième de ce qu'ils
arrivent sur terre
pour satisfaire nos besoins donc il ya
des méthodes de captage qui ont été mis
au point qu'il a été mais par henri
becquerel le même qui a inventé la
radioactivité et la nature et la nature
comment il fonctionne elle fonctionne
avec la photosynthèse qui est qui et du
photovoltaïque pêcheurs donc voilà pour
moi l'avenir c'est le nucléaire j'essaie
de me mettre à la place d'un dollar
nucléaire on se met on se met réellement
dans la peau d'un pro nucléaire
faites-moi le spin doctor du nucléaire
celui qui est chargé devriez la tête des
gens et pour faire passer un message en
travestissant en langue française
pourquoi un pro-nucléaire un intérêt à
défendre ce business là pourquoi la
france un intérêt à défendre ce business
là
la france est dépendante
de son énergie de ses exportations de sa
capacité à survivre dans un climat de
guerre économique
est-ce que c'est peut-être pour ça que
la france se raccroche désespérément à
cette technologie vieillissante est ce
que vous voyez là où je veux en venir
ben moi là où je
voulais en venir moi je vois la france
là je reviens d'une ancienne colonie
kinshasa de thé pas de la france mais
une ancienne colonie
la france avait un empire la france est
rentrée dans l'es5 le top 5 des nations
avec le droit de veto
ça reste encore du d'afrique une nation
puissante mais c'est une nation
décadente en termes de puissance il lui
reste pas grand chose à dire au niveau
économique au niveau financier il reste
les choses sont bien dégradé
le nucléaire fait partie des derniers
attribuent on peut avoir quand on a
perdu son empire qui est la capacité de
vendre des centrales nucléaires donc ans
ou moins de 10 les larmes nucléaire
comme l'a fait en pakistan on l'a fait
on l'a fait aussi en israël on l'a fait
avec l'afrique du sud enfin on est le 10
rendons aussi dans un peu long oui on a
commencé en iran mais une rupture de
contrat ce qui a fait des israéliens
sont passés par là voilà ouais une rue
non du changement de politique ça s'est
fini au châtelet avec des attentats pour
faire payer la note face à ces c'est
l'anecdote mais
mais
en fait ça reste géostratégique comme
sur le nucléaire c'est le c'est l'objet
géostratégique qui permet d'avoir un peu
du poids sur la scène politique quand on
en a de moins en moins et nos élites qui
ne veulent pas renoncer au fait qu'on
ait une nation modeste et qui pourrait
avoir en fait et on est une puissance de
moyenne puissance ouais parce qu'on peut
formuler ça comme ça on est venu
oui les mots puissants oui moyennement
un puissant avec une capacité d'
influence encore mais on
s'accroche à ça parce que il ya encore
il reste sur ses skis c'est ce qui reste
le roi est nu et du reste encore deux
trois bijoux de famille quoi problème
c'est que ses bijoux de famille vont
nous coûter comme le corse parler de
l'impact de la colonisation sur les
fédérations futur va nous faire rater ce
que les allemands sont en train de
réussir c'est à dire la transition
énergétique et le fait de bailly feront
que dalle comme transition énergétique
les allemands ils tapent dans le charbon
google
moi je serais pas d'accord non les
allemands sont il ya toute une
propagande pour moi qui est construite
aussi par d'une dizaine comment le spin
doctor oui mais avant une dizaine
nucléaire c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux les
autres ça marche pas
quand j'ai fait mes études on m'a dit tu
verras les éoliennes photovoltaïques
l'on en verra jamais en france c'est ça
le premier discours que j'ai eu
il existe l'allemagne et la chine deux
pays les deux gros pays qui ont investi
dans photovoltaïque baisse leur
consommation de charbon
actuellement il la baisse alors en chine
je crois qu'il ya une centrale à charbon
ou qu'ils construisent chaque semaine
non ben cette recette projection qui a
été fait cette cette information qui a
été vrai pendant un moment et fausses
maintenant car face à la pollution les
chinois et vu qu'ils ont voulu se
positionner mais dans 80% du silicium
effet ils ont ils ont racheté toute
l'industrie les français qui était
numéro un du ya 30 ans du photovoltaïque
sont les numéros
ouais
sont les numéros et les chinois sont
positionnés et arrête de construire ont
décidé d'arrêter de construire des
centrales nucléaires et remplacer sa
part de l'éolien et du photovoltaïque
oui c'est je suis d'accord ils ont aussi
arrêté d'en porter toute la merde dumont
pour la retraitée chez eux ils
commencent à s'installer oppose les deux
groupes façon si on est si on en a fine
le problème de l'énergie qui est un
problème jr fondamental c'est dire qu'il
ya une transition à faire quoi qu'on
veut quoi qu'on fasse quoi qu'on fasse
la une transition à faire il reste qui
reste 40 ans ou 50 ans ou peu importe à
l'échelle du matin une transition à
faire
comme on est passé de la chasse à
l'agriculture comme on est passé du bois
au charbon il faut qu'on passe du en
faut qu'on passe des énergies fossiles
et c'est une énergie fossile l'uranium y
en a il ya très peu de stock françois
pro nucléaire et donc dont 40 ans il y
en a plus le paradis le parallèle est
très intéressant entre la chasse et ça à
chaque fois qu'il ya une transition
énergétique par exemple du charbon
électricité et les l'hydrolien et de
l'hydrolienne nucléaire il ya eu une
consommation exponentielle
d'énergie ce qui a entamé de la
croissance on qu'est ce qu'on fait dans
un monde sans croissance avec cette
énergie est ce que le nucléaire est fait
pour être dans un monde sans croissance
le nucléaire ça représentait à rien ça
vous même pas le coup j'essaie de dire
ça représente 2 % de la production
mondiale de l'énergie ça aucun avenir
parce que ça s'est produit dans les
étoiles du soleil au moins le pétrole
tout renouvelable le pétrole tout près
300 millions d'années et se régénère
mais il n'y a rien eu à faire avec le
nucléaire donc autant prendre un risque
et ensuite dans un monde d'énergie
renouvelable énergie et plus chère elle
est moins abondante ça je suis d'accord
et ça veut dire que la croissance elle
n'est plus là et on est en décroissance
et ça veut dire comment on paye les
intérêts des rentiers on ne peut plus
dans un monde sans croissance donc un
mot parce que la croissance est liée à
l'énergie donc un monde sans croissance
c'est un monde où les rentiers n'ont
forcément pas la même place j'ai réussi
à vous faire bugger
les énergies du soleil c'était pas mal
bon bon derrière que dernière question
qui est commune à toutes nos émissions
c'est l'essai c'est même pas une
question s'est laissé un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
c'est une bouteille à la mer qui est qui
et laissées sur internet
donc trois minutes pour laisser
un conseil aux jeunes générations par
exemple la génération qui regardera
cette vidéo quand on aura tous
quatre bras trois jambes 18 testicules
et trois yeux
qu'est ce qu'on leur donne comme conseil
comme conseils je leur donnerai de
de bien profiter
de bien profiter du moment présent de
bien profiter à
se construire
à se construire nous à vivre des choses
heureuses
caire
je suis pas très optimiste
je suis vraiment pas optimiste est la
différence entre un optimiste et un
pessimiste c'est que le pessimiste il
est bien informé et
et moi je leur conseillerais de
voilà de vivre de bien vivre une
dernière question parce que je les
oublier celle ci c'est une question de
l'internet est ce que les nations qui
nous entourent par exemple la belgique
elle est inquiète du risque nucléaire
français avec tout son parc qui
vieillissant et
est compliquée ce que les autres nations
à ce que vous avez entendu parler de
l'espagne qui s'inquiéteraient si ça
pète et en france ou la belgique le
luxembourg dans le sens luxembourg et a
rencontré manuel valls et il lui a dit
on voudrait vous faire mieux qu'à 14 la
centrale qui est juste à la frontière et
va lancer notre centrale c'est nous qui
décidons et puis ça coûte cher le
luxembourg non paye on paye la fermeture
rubis sur l'ongle
ça veut dire qu'on fait ça ça veut dire
que flip oui ça veut dire quand y'a pas
de problème je paye c'est quand vous
allez voir votre voisin où il dit je
paye les travaux là ça pas de problème
mais je paye ta maison s'écroule sur ma
gueule voilà bon josep lucky merci
beaucoup d'être passés nous voir désolé
de vous avoir pris à la sortie de votre
avion fatiguée et avait que huit heures
de vol merci d'être passé juste sur vous
dire que l'on peut retrouver
participé à la fondation du nhs d'une
web tv qui s'appelle la longueur de la
chaîne la longueur de la chaîne point fr
tout attaché on mesure la liberté à la
longueur de la chaîne et et c'est une
petite web tv locale qui parle notamment
d'énergie et sur lequel vous pouvez
retrouver des vidéos etc voilà pour
sentir sa liberté il faut qu'il
commençait à faire bouger ses chaînes
ouais merci merci avocate de faim merci
[Musique]
e